&gt;&gt; In the last few quizzes, we figured out that if could get a quadratic
equation in this form right here, with two factors involving an x to the first
power multiplied together. Then we could pretty easily find out where its x
intercepts are. Or where that parabola cuts the x axis. Awesome. Just to cement
that idea, let's do one more practice example involving these concepts. Let's
say then, that we have the equation y equals x minus 4 times x plus 3. If I want
to find out, where this curve, intersects with the x axis, or in other words,
where its x intercepts are, what equation do we need to solve? Please write your
answer in this box. Also, at this point, we don't need to multiply out anything,
or simplify at all. This is really just a one step problem at this point.